as I've kind of you know gone along in
my career I was a geophysicist first I
worked for all the gas companies I'm
subsurface mapping as a well side
geologist I did seismic data processing
and then I became a mortgage broker
which would seem like it's not a likely
path for a vodka maker actually in the
end it ended up being like the perfect
recipe in my mind for a vodka maker the
turning point for me was when I saw this
guy on TV and he said if you're trying
to figure out what to do with your life
you take a sheet of paper and you draw a
line down the middle and on one side you
put what you love to do on the other
side you put what you're good at
it's usually good to have like a few
glasses of Tito's before you do this
just to kind of loosen yourself up a
little truth serum and then you sit
there you look at it and you try to
incorporate everything you wrote it down
as many things as possible into what
your dream job is and the theory behind
it is that if you're doing something
that you love to do that you're good at
then you'll work harder at it and you'll
probably be better at it and you won't
feel like you're busting your ass you'll
feel like you're going out you're having
fun you're doing stuff that you would
normally want to do anyway whether you
got paid for it or not for me going out
you know to this little shack that I
built out in the country you know and
cooking you know cooking booze and
sitting there like tasting you know
these little test tubes just as it's
coming off the still I mean to me that
did not seem like work to me and there's
still dead and I just I still enjoyed
you know going out there and a few tests
soups in my back pocket and so you know
what I spend you know a lot of time
doing work yeah I mean I had a cot out
there I live there out you know I'm
gonna live next to the still with my dog
you know and and so yeah I spent a lot
of time doing it and you know but but I
enjoyed it you know I think that's kind
of all part of it I mean as far as like
hard work it's like I don't know you
know I guess there's people who that our
workers and
aren't you no but I've always just
looked at it like you know I enjoy
working you know when I'm not working I
just tend to like sleep late or later
next ain't like like it's like 3:30 in
the afternoon you know I don't do well
these people is like you know I'm like
an old bird dog got to keep me working
all the time or I'll be out chasing
rabbits or something yeah so so hard
work and tenacity you know following
your dreams you know hitting it against
the odds like yeah I'm having set out to
build a big nationwide vodka company I
really just set out to you know meet
some girls right off my bar tab you know
I could make like 1,200 bucks a month
you know just be awesome you know it's
just I mean it just kind of kept going
and going and going and going and yeah
and it worked out